Mitt Romney revealed recently to the
Atlantic that he has a secret twitter
account under the name Pierre de lecto
probably heard about this and it got me
thinking about this other Twitter
account you may or may not know about
it's an account that tweets only gossip
and criticism about me Conan O'Brien I
find it very hurtful this Twitter
account also uses a pseudonym
Antoine disgruntle now I was looking at
this site looking back at some of Aunt
Wanda's grunt OHS recent tweets and I
actually think it's someone who works
here in the building
with me check this out Conan pays his
staff to laugh at rehearsals and they
still refuse okay that's true all right
but only someone who works here would
know that here's another one Conan's
fuse is almost as short as his jacket
what a temper it's clearly someone who
works here and has a bone to pick with
me and doesn't like the way I dress and
think it's phony looking here's another
one his wig is made of squirrel and
smells like it so this is someone who's
close enough to me day in and day out to
smell me and actually knows what I smell
like you know what I mean that's
ridiculous then check this one out the
right side of Conan's face is really
after
who's on the right side it's Andy Andy I
mean this is seriously yeah Andy are you
Antwon disgruntled no I swear I mean to
be completely honest I do have a secret
Twitter account that I use to gossip
about you but that's not it mine is a
Marcel complain iary oh okay well if
you're not its who's Antoine de scrunt
Oh Tony the cameraman is it you nope
my secret Twitter account that I used to
[ __ ] on you is called Frenchie Mick
well Jeff isn't you
nope I'm not you under the name armand
de les scoop I'm on it
what about my trusty assistant Sona Sona
is it is it you are you the one doing
this nope mines Genevieve hates her job
wait a minute then who's Antoine
disgruntle Conan it can't be any of us
really because Aunt Wanda's Franco just
tweeted again it says you'll never catch
me
whoa ha ha ha ha ha well guess we'll
never know who Antoine disgruntle is
unless unless what unless you created
Antoine disgruntle so that we would all
reveal our secret Twitter accounts
I guess we'll never know
[Music]
[Applause]